foreign
B joins us up next in San Diego B
welcome to the show
guys thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can Christina and I help
um okay so I'm kind of nervous it's all
right you're gonna do fine we're
freaking out too
that helps thank you uh well it's kind
of bad but uh so I called
back in I want to say like April 2020 uh
for my debt-free screen and it was um
with uh Steve Ramsey and Dr John deloney
and I was like super excited
um
especially like heading into a pandemic
I just felt like super relieved that I
had gotten out of debt
um but then like
I saved up the emergency fund I started
investing like doing everything that
um like following the baby steps
and then I
um kind of like drained my emergency
account to start a Roth IRA
um with like a financial Pro
and
um I never really got like my emergency
fund built back up before like Murphy
started hitting so that's how it goes I
know so I kind of ended up back in in
debt and I was like
well I'll I'll make a goal to pay it off
in a year and
um and that year passed a couple months
ago and I'm still like looking at this
10 grand that I owe and uh what kind of
debt is it I'm
it's on my car
okay so you didn't have the emergency
fund you had car problems you had to get
a new car and so you bought a car on a
loan
yes okay
um I I bought it for 14 and over the
past year I've only really paid off like
about four of it you just been making
the minimum payments pretty much
yeah I essentially just like rounded up
to like the like to 500 so it's like
I've been making extra payment for it I
just haven't been like intentional with
it
how much um and I just feel like a
hypocrite and I'm like that's all right
hey you know what Dave's not here we're
gonna treat this like a Planet Fitness
this is a judgment-free Zone today we're
not gonna beat you up
the fact that you called you showed up
you were vulnerable and honest it's okay
yeah how much debt did you pay off the
first time
oh my God like 47
000 wow how long did that take
um
it took me about a year and a half
to do that and that was the same person
who stands before us today saying they
can't pay off ten thousand in a year
yeah why is that
I honestly I really hate to like
I've been actually thinking about that
for a couple days now but
I when I was paying all that stuff off I
lived
um on like the east coast and I didn't
really like have much to like do where I
lived and now I live in San Diego and
I'm doing all these like crazy fun
things what I'm hearing is your
lifestyle creeped up you got a little
bit lazy and we went we're in California
let's have a good time and here we are
exactly
and I'm just like I don't need to pay
off my car but like in the back of my
mind I'm like why do I have this stupid
debt like I hate this
um when you called in back in 2020 and
you were talking through your debt-free
scream what was your why in that moment
when they were asking you what motivated
you to pay off forty seven thousand
dollars in debt what was your motivation
then
um honestly I had two motivations I
wanted um I was kind of like wanted to
prove to my family that like you didn't
need to rely on debt
um because like my whole family
background is like you know we lost our
house during the 2008 recession and all
that stuff so I've just kind of always
had like Financial trauma surrounding my
family
um so like that was my biggest push was
to like
be an idol for like my younger siblings
if that makes any sense I don't know
that makes sense it absolutely does you
that was your never again you said my
family tree is going to look a lot
different because the decisions that I
made I think we need to channel back to
those days and go I know it I hate to be
here and I made decisions that weren't
great and I used my emergency fund as an
investment tool and I know I did I made
some mistakes great let's pick it up and
move forward and go what can we do now
so what is your income
okay
um
um it just increased that I make about 8
000 a month
B that's an amazing income why is this
debt not gone you know two three months
from now
that's a great question can you live off
nothing for the next two months and
clear the debt R2 so in my brain I'm
like
I don't even like my car it was just
something I bought real quick in like
how much could you sell the car for
foreign
probably 12 or 14 000. and how much do
you have in the bank
I want to say around seven thousand okay
this is a non-issue if you want to be
debt free today go sell the car and get
you a five six seven eight thousand
dollar car
yeah that you like more and be who are
you hanging out with in San Diego it
sounds like you've changed communities
you've got a different lifestyle do you
have any other friends who are Frugal
who are kind of thinking the same way
you are about money
or at least the way you want to think
about money
um no honestly like all my friends are
into like the whole credit card Point
thing and all that stuff but um
but are you married every time
oh no okay
no no no no no no no she said okay I'm
just figuring out who we can use to keep
you accountable on this journey because
it sounds like it's pretty lonely and
you're just out there living la vida
loca with no one to tell you hey maybe
we should pay off some debt and make
some grown-up decisions
yeah exactly yeah and this was also like
my first time sort of like living alone
too so like back when I paid off debt I
you know I had like roommates that were
like a part of the process and they were
just like checking things off with me
and stuff so now it's just me and my dog
that was fun well it sounds like you do
great in community I would encourage you
to find a local FPU class and actually
go to that and get cheerleaders around
you get other people around you who are
walking through this journey who are
motivated who aren't going to be people
that you're comparing yourself to and
feeling that fomo like you want people
around you who will be your cheerleaders
and are excited for you paying off debt
not talking about the latest the latest
credit card reward deal yeah have you
been through fbu yeah I mean have
um when did you go through it actually
twice I think I've been through it I
used to make it like a yearly goal to go
to do it again but then
um sounds like the pandemic and all that
stuff and all the stuff shut down I just
kind of like lost track of
um well you know what they say third
time's the charm and so what we're gonna
do is gift you uh Financial Peace
University for one year it's got the
latest videos in there including a new
new lessons with Dr John deloney and
myself and I hope that's the motivation
you need I can't sit here and and make
you motivated you've got to find your
own why and use that to drive your
budget your behavior your lifestyle and
you have an amazing income and you have
money in the bank throw six of that at
the debt take it down to four and this
month we're debt free on your next
paycheck it's that simple it's just you
have to decide am I going to do this
stuff or am I going to keep living in
the shame and guilt and baggage or do I
just want to move forward completely
debt free once and for all you get to
decide I hope you make the right choice